Although it is true that we fall in love,
that does not mean that once we fall, we just
simply lie there.
The infatuating sense of love that we feel
when we first fall for someone cannot last
forever.
This sensation is merely the brain’s way
of attempting to motivate reproduction.
It comes, works to do its job, and then leaves.
But the relationship formed from it does not
have to.
If the relationship is honest and worthy,
the true love underneath can live on.
True love can perpetuate when one understands
that, like everything in life, love goes through
various stages and conditions.
It molds to our unique and changing life,
and we must adapt and react accordingly.
The unconscious and lustful love that we experience
during the honeymoon-phase of relationships
is often easy and carefree.
But this phase will eventually fade, and you
must ensure that the individuals that you
choose to engage in relationships with for
the purpose of love are individuals of whom
you will still want and enjoy love with when
the roses die.
True love requires effort.
And you must work to ensure that such effort
is worthwhile.
Like everything in life, you get what you
put in.
And things that are worth a lot, require a
lot.
By being aware of and embracing the effort
that must come after the initial surge of
love flees, you can work to facilitate love
beyond just lust and romance.
You can merge your life with another persons
and experience the wonder of genuine connection.
We must constantly check our pride and ego
within a relationship and prevent any sense
of comfort, selfishness, or routine within
it.
You must be mindful and consider what differences
you and your partner have.
What is it that they like that you do not,
and vice versa?
We must not let our selfishness prevent us
from providing a balanced and mutual exchange
of love according to each partners’ needs
and preferences.
We must constantly make sacrifices and be
willing to give up portions of our life that
help balance out our partners, trusting that
they will do the same for us.
As scary as this may be, it is one of the
only risks worth taking in life.
A life experienced without connection and
love is a life unfulfilled.
It is an incomplete work of art.
If we wish to earn the experience of true
love and fulfill the work of art that is our
life, we must realize the balance between
the unconscious, infatuating acquisition of
love, and the conscious conservation of it.